es ist sonntag meiner lieben freund und
was macht man dann am sonntag richtig
gar nichts deswegen habe ich hier schon
den ganzen tag in meinem bett rum
gestern man sandra carola und sowie bei
junioren mir hier in köln zu besuchen
und wir haben uns den spontanen
entschluss gefasst dass wir zu einem
horror haus fahren in köln also zu
seiner verlassenen will ein bisschen
außerhalb ich wollte das ganze blog und
habe es auch geblockt also ihr seht
gleich die aufnahmen
die sache ist nur als wenn diesen grusel
haus ankamen waren alle fenster
zugemauert die türen man abgesperrt als
mann kam da nicht rein von daher ist der
block hat ziemlich kurz geworden und ich
habe das gerade geschnitten und es ging
nur vier viereinhalb minuten oder so von
daher wollte ich jetzt direkt sagen hey
ein sorry aber es war ein paar lustige
sehen dabei deswegen wollte ich es
trotzdem hochladen also viel spaß bei
dem blog herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
ja klar für heute ist das uns jetzt
erstmal unser fahrer james abholt james
dass unser fahrer selbst also eigentlich
so komisch an ist aber es hört sich
irgendwie cool aussteigen und jetzt
abgeholt
wir fahren jetzt zum haus fühlingen das
ist ein grusel haus in köln so sieht
dieses große haus auf wurden vier
menschen im monat geben das alle fünf
besitzer denen dieses mal gehört hat
sich dort selbst umgebracht haben weil
ja völlig entspannt auch klargekommen am
parkplatz james hat uns erfolgreiche
abgesetzt haben vor dem hässlichsten
auto der welt geparkt
und wir gehen jetzt ab zum gruße haus
hier liegt ein teil von dem auto im wald
also hier ist halt so der normale weg
dahin sind noch zur fußballplätze und
hier geht es da den wald rein und da
hinten das gleich das haus zwischen den
bäumen sieht man schon so ein bisschen
das haus okay leute die ersten
hindernisse hier hindern uns daran zum
haus sei aber wir haben es geschafft sie
sind angekommen am grusel hause im
fühlinger see und so sieht es aus in der
regel alter scheißegal sind jetzt
wirkliche von james wie hast du dich
aufs auto also sieht das haus von vorne
aus man kann immer hier rumlaufen hier
vorne ist die garage auf jeden fall das
weiß ich noch ja genau hier vorne drin
standen wohl irgendwie autos von den
leuten die hier drin gewohnt haben was
das dass sie für ein gerät als ich das
letzte mal war war halt irgendwie herbst
oder früher oder so unterschieden
zumindest noch ein bisschen die sonne
und jetzt gerade alles so so sieht das
ganze haus von vorne los und hier zur
straße hin steht auch irgendwie so ein
schild guthof haben sie verkauft
das ding wird verkauft gerade dass sie
den hilfe kurs foto machen
sie achte aus letzte mal als wir hier
waren stand das halt alles offen
ja da war gar nichts kann das ist hier
alles gegen die zugemacht worden
kann das wirklich mich im weg
das christlich nicht aufkommen die haben
alle fenster zugemacht da oben hier auch
das dann alles offen letztes macht dann
habe ich halt noch den masterplan darf
vielleicht rein kommen könnte ja hat
nicht geklappt so sieht es da drinnen
eigentlich alles andere zur eröffnung
für uns sieht es momentan wenn du dir
hier sind auch alle fenster zu sein
da komm ich glaub ich nicht so schnell
in die garagen hier sind halt alle noch
offen aber was will man in der garage
voller kommt jetzt eine irgendwie an und
streitig
dann kamen wir irgendwie auf die dumme
idee vor sandra wegzulaufen uns vorher
zu verstecken
zwei minuten später wir uns dann wieder
gefunden
das kann echt ein bisschen traurig das
letztmals hier weiß halt auch jetzt
schon fast ein jahr her glaube ich
bleibe lieber noch länger
aber das ist noch offen aber jetzt ok
man kann halt durchgucken selbst ja um
ist zugemauert also dass wir sind die
eingänge zu diesem gruß zu hause sind
alle irgendwie also offen gebrochen ist
halt ein offenes fenster was man jetzt
so wie kommen wir da rein
das war es jetzt nehmen wir wollten
eigentlich rein gehen aber es hat halt
nicht geklappt ich habe hundert prozent
action gegeben für die scheiße hier sind
wieder zurück im auto angekommen muss
anderer dissidenten wir sind alle hier
fordere rauskommen aus dem weg und
sandra wo warst du schon mal eine hose
an
ja das war so circa der unnötigste weg
den ich je gemacht habe bald im
endeffekt echt ein bisschen traurig dass
da alles abgesperrt war das natürlich
verständlich wenn die dasding verkaufen
wollen wir wollen natürlich auch nicht
irgendwelche gesetze brechen oder
irgendwas kaputt machen oder irgendwas
nur ich wollte das schon immer gern mal
reingehen und jetzt ist es anscheinend
zu spät habe ich glaube es gibt auch
coole dinge die man machen kann als in
so einem grusel haus zu gehen wo leute
gestorben sind auf jeden fall war es das
jetzt hier mit dem blog ich klatsche mir
selbst weil ich so toll fand wenig dass
wir trotzdem gefallen das gerne mal
einen daumen hoch da schreibt mir die
kommentare was wir heute haben sonst hat
bisher alles gemacht hat oder ob ja auch
gerade im bett liegt und sonst
[Musik]